لقد انتهى وقف إطلاق النار، يمكننا بالفعل
سماع القصف وأنا في أحد المستشفيات،
كانت هناك ضربة على بعد حوالي 50 مترًا من هنا.
هذا هو أكبر مستشفى لا يزال يعمل
في غزة، تبلغ طاقته 200٪
نعم، هذا مستشفى، النظام الصحي
هنا  المستشفى غارق ببساطة
ولا يمكنه استيعاب المزيد من الأطفال المصابين
بجروح الحرب، هناك أطفال في
كل مكان ينام هؤلاء الأطفال،
كانت هناك قنبلة على بعد 50 مترًا من
هنا، لا أستطيع أن أذكر كيف
تم تخفيض الطاقة الاستيعابية للمستشفيات
في الأسابيع السبعة الماضية، لا يمكننا أن نرى  المزيد من
الأطفال المصابين بجراح الحرب مع
الحروق مع الشظايا التي تتناثر
أجسادهم مع كسور العظام في تصرفات
أصحاب
النفوذ
هو السماح بقتل
الأطفال هذه حرب على
الأطفال